wenn 5000 kilometer und der atlantik
einander trennen wenn man sich
monatelang nicht gesehen hat oder nicht
weiß wann es wieder möglich ist dann ist
liebe nicht einfach da ist er ist seit
13 tagen allein in istanbul damit er in
die usa zu seiner freundin reisen darf
da ist michelle sie hat gerade ihren
negativen corona test bekommen jetzt
trennen die amerikanerin und ihren
freund in europa nur noch ein flug und
da sind lisa und gerrit die sich nach
wunderschönen gemeinsamen wochen wieder
verabschieden müssen
das alles ist liebe in zeiten von corona
[Musik]
istanbul in der türkei das ist so aus
england er ist hier zwangsweise auf
zwischenstopp um in die usa zu seiner
freundin liz zu fliegen die er seit elf
monaten nicht gesehen hat dann long
distance wir führen seit zwei jahren
eine fernbeziehung
aber das ist die längste zeit die wir
bisher getrennt waren und uns nicht
persönlich sehen bisher waren es
vielleicht zwei oder drei monate es war
echt schwierig für uns beide so ist
brite aber weil er von bristol nicht
direkt zu liz in die usa fliegen darf
muss er den umweg über istanbul nehmen
[Musik]
wegen corona verweigern die usa seit
mitte märz bürger innen aus dem
schengenraum die einreise
außer man hat mindestens 14 tage vorher
europa schon verlassen um neue fälle
davon abzuhalten unsere grenzen zu
erreichen setzen wir jegliche reisen aus
europa in die usa für 30 tage aus aus
dreißig tagen wurden mittlerweile 40
wochen
der traumstadt travel bahn ist nach wie
vor intakt und hindert
amerikanisch-europäische pärchen
offiziell daran sich zu sehen
inoffiziell machen es tausende
mit umwegen über drittstaaten auch lisa
und gerrit haben sich so wieder gesehen
weil lisa aus deutschland und gerrit aus
den usa kommt haben sie sich auf kuba in
der karibik getroffen
14 tage sind sie dort bevor sie dann
gemeinsam in die usa reisen können
[Musik]
als ich sie gesehen habe als ich auf dem
flughafen gekommen bin das erste mal
seit sieben monaten fühlte sich an wie
ein traum nicht wirklich real
ich habe da gewartet und mein herz so
schnell geschlagen und als er herauskam
war es einfach nur wir treffen die
beiden anfang dezember in virginia wo
garrett wohnt die einreise aus der
karibik war für lisa kein problem mehr
seit über einem jahr sind die 23 und der
25-jährige zusammen
dieser studiert in hamburg das
wiedersehen war nur möglich weil sie
jetzt semesterferien hat durch rbs und
relativ günstige ferienwohnung und
selber kochen und solche sachen
was dann auch erschwinglich auch der
flug war nicht so teuer wie gedacht aber
natürlich sechs wochen war lisa bei
gerrit in den usa sechs wochen ohne
video calls und ohne zeitverschiebung
doch die semesterferien sind vorbei lisa
und gerrit müssen abschied nehmen
sie fliegt zurück nach deutschland
jetzt wir haben es noch nicht richtig
realisiert aber es fängt langsam an
ich glaube sobald wir zum gate
aufbrechen fange ich an zu weinen
eine fernbeziehung war schon vor corona
nicht einfach nun bringen unsicherheit
und zusätzliche kosten viele paare an
ihre grenzen
doch lisa und gerrit wollen nicht
aufgeben zurück in istanbul auch so gibt
nicht auf in seinen 14 tagen außerhalb
des schengen raums ist er zwar nicht
eingesperrt in der ferienwohnung der
kann sich frei bewegen
doch die tage allein können lang sein
ich habe mir einige touristen
attraktionen angeschaut aber ich habe
auch viel zeit drinnen verbracht und
einfach nur gewartet warten
das muss die amerikanerin michelle nicht
mehr sie hat ein flugticket nach europa
ergattert ihr freund alex spielt seit
vier monaten basketball in porto jetzt
kann sie endlich zu ihm nach portugal
die letzte hürde ist der korona test im
drive-in ich mache jetzt mein zweiter
corona test
das ergebnis könnte bis zu 70 stunden
dauern und es sind nur noch 24 stunden
bis zu meinem flug
ich mache es trotzdem
ich bin wirklich aufgeregt nervös und
gespannt
ich will jetzt einfach losfahren und
mein freund wiedersehen es waren lange
vier monate ich hoffe es klappt alles
abends kommt dann endlich ihr
testergebnis
der test ist negativ endlich kann es
losgehen fünf monate portugal mit ihrem
freund isaac liegen vorher die
sicherheitskontrolle hat sie geschafft
jetzt heißt es warten auf den abflug
[Musik]
auch joe hat mittlerweile das gate am
istanbuler flughafen erreicht sein co
wie test ist negativ er darf an bord das
war's ich bin sehr aufgeregt gerade
endlich geht es los
ich freue mich sehr darauf jetzt wieder
zu sehen aber auch darauf endlich
anzukommen nach dieser langen reise es
wird sich alles gelohnt haben am ende
nach 15 tagen in istanbul ist der reise
bann gebrochen
jetzt folgen elf stunden flug nach
chicago und fünf stunden autofahrt dann
ist ja am ziel in ohio
währenddessen ist michelle im
landeanflug auf portugal bei der
einreise gibt es keine probleme
alles hat geklappt ich bin gerade am
bahnhof und warte auf meinen freund ich
bin so erleichtert dass alles geklappt
hat während dieser reise
jetzt muss ich nur noch auf ihn warten
er müsste jeden moment da sein und dann
ist es soweit nach über vier monaten
sieht sie isaac wieder für die beiden
beginnt jetzt in portugal endlich ein
neuer abschnitt im leben
corona hat beziehungen auf eine harte
probe gestellt sie alle haben mit
problemen gekämpft aber nie aufgegeben
immer mit der hoffnung dass alles bald
wieder besser wird
denn das ist liebe in zeiten von krone
[Musik]